dude you gotta love the street fighter
music it's so good it's so good it's so
Timeless I love that all that music just
like stays with the franchise I know I
pretty much just had Ken's theme and
Guile's Theme up the whole time just
waiting for the stream to come on does
go with everything so what's up guys uh
I'm Joey from Gamespot this is Scott
hello and what we are going to be doing
today is going through the entire
cinematic story mode yes the new DLC
that Capcom finally released yeah
finally is the key word there they they
promise a June update but you know
they're one day late yeah they I mean
what listen it's here uh you can split
hairs and be like they promised you but
like I don't know it was already late in
my mind it's like
if it comes out July 1st then that's you
know fine whatever I'm just happy it's
here it's close enough to see what's
what's going on with it I've heard sort
of conflicting things like I've already
seen a bunch of gifts yeah on Twitter of
like various cutscenes that occur
throughout the story mode and some of
them are absolutely ridiculous that's
what exactly what I'm expecting I just
want cheese ridiculous so let's let's
Jump Right In yeah I really hope they
lean into it I mean Street Fighter has
always been kind of fun for its like
level of personality and just like the
sort of wackiness that's just under the
surface so I really hope they leaned
into that with the story mode but I
guess we'll find out very soon we're
gonna try to make it from beginning to
end we don't necessarily know how long
the campaign is we're thinking like a
couple hours a few hours well the First
Act is called disaster so it's oh that's
perfect that's yeah off to a good start
so yeah we'll see how far we make it
we're gonna stick with it as long as we
can and uh hopefully they make it all
the way through yeah we'll see
you're along for the ride
also we'll be trying to keep an eye on
chat
no disaster so all right so I'm gonna
during these parts I'm gonna let you
guys listen in on it
devour
S
I must devour
wow
[Music]
you have regained Consciousness it's a
miracle
my name is Helen
I've been asked to take care of you
your nurse so to speak
you had broken bones everywhere
at first
I thought you were already dead
but what happened to you
I remember
boys
you must save your strength
foreign
spectacular we are off to an amazing
start
there's a sheep for no reason crazy
dream sequence you're fighting ghost
bison this is really weird like pink
translucent bison
so Charlie was in a sarcophagus
oh everything about this is insane and
awesome so far
I'm gonna let you concentrate what he's
doing oh my God how's it going do you
normally play Nash no I don't play them
at all yeah that's gonna be the weird
thing like I always struggled with the
uh the Mortal Kombat campaigns that
they've started doing over the past few
games because it forces you to play as
every character and there are plenty of
characters that like I've had literally
never played until I was forced to play
as them in the campaign yeah well this
will this will help get us all like
yes well-rounded hopefully oh is that
just yeah some single round
it's pretty well man
[Music]
but uh yeah that was a very successful
first round
oh please look at the sky and go bison
so much
seriously that hat and that dress do not
make sense is it 90 degrees or 20
degrees
a little bit of both they're in the
jungle they are in the jungle also what
part of the world has like Egyptian
sarcophagi and like a nice beautiful
waterfall right outside I mean what
I think we're missing some important
story
let's find this man
I'm gonna get guile if you want to
defeat bison
I knew it yeah
look at that flat top
and she's gone
very mystical story so far
also left his cropped vest
get to the Air Force midriff going
so far I'm impressed they they really
committed to the cutscenes I know these
are lengthy substantial cutscenes I mean
people have been asking for this for
years and years like put something
substantial
in the Street Fighter game so
how did
it's so perfect I need your help
fighting stance Yep this is the real we
all know here we go awesome old Del
scene whose beard is clipping through
his scarf but that's okay I'll show you
the way let's go
also they're apparently not big on
Segways in this story just like we're
still like totally unrelated to what's
happening with Charlie we are now in
somewhere in India nice hit
doesn't get Joey got them cornered
punishing in the corner oh no
there we go that was even easier than
the fake license plates
single round again yep single round
all right so I'm gonna
yeah you don't need to look at a full
game here
we're not exciting were you staring at
this is exciting completely
continue to suppressor will be consumed
by
it once again it was so itchy you need
to face the heart that you are hiding
inside
across the border
really likes it oh
[Music]
what's that
in Japanese
dude no it doesn't look like it I am the
Justice Warriors
oh really
it does a lot to switch
uh to the side like you're now on the
right side
I might just let you keep playing this
whole time man you're killing it so far
[Music]
do not let the software know how to take
you over
thank you
so how do you feel about yourself
because I haven't played much with five
at all honestly I'm really curious
he also is my character man
I don't know if this does get harder
because you are like crushing these
dudes so far I know
good man
what's that
son
melodrama is so thick
Ness is messing with everybody
oh you see that oh dude that looks back
hey thanks for getting that joke
only 90s kids will remember
long ago I was told about an ancient
being who consumes Warrior's Souls
this ancient being only appears at a
time when many warriors are needed that
is when the world is in a time of great
crisis
the world is in
prices it's a crisis
God are you
now we're in space
uh yeah sure
no it's got to be um
oh no it's this dude Rasheed
is he like a good guy is he shadowlu or
is he uh no he's good yeah okay
I wasn't sure where he fit into like the
story Cannon oh it's refighter
I wonder if those guys are bad
anybody that looks like Skeletor is
probably bad
you just can't ignore someone in
distress
that's a little strange
I mean how many shooters have just like
fought or enemy for you to mow down yeah
that's kind of what I'm guessing that
guy was
Rasheed
is this guy's ass no time flat we will
get out of here right after I never saw
the close-up of his beard like that
what
captured by those soldiers
did it look like it
seems complicated
hey little girl have you seen this
person
[Music]
bingo
do you perhaps know where they are
laughs
in there a photo of
thank you guys I don't get your
situations
he's so beguiling
first of several inevitable puns
how's Chad doing you're looking over
chat hi chat
sandals
yeah dude six sandals I think they're
tivas
oh it's this guy yeah
this smell isn't bad at all
but anyone betrays Lord bison is my
enemy
I must erase you leaving nothing behind
it's so ugly but he's so great
hey man
[Music]
who's now old compared to like previous
iterations no well previous iterations
he was old now he's just really really
old I guess all right grew a beard oh
his hand
oh you arrived sooner than I expected
oh that's what he turned that guy into
oh
good sir I just came by them so
apparently they're saying that can we
discuss uh all the NPC fires have moves
so we didn't even give him a chance to
try that out you're just too good Joey
you gotta take it easy that's it
do you want this well why don't we make
this great exception that looks like
talk to him actually
destroy you
he's really strange yeah
[Music]
it's done in I really hope
thank you there's just one difficulty no
I just I just went straight in okay yeah
I hope this does get more difficult
because you're just whipping through
this
damn it
right you only had one of them
now we can let festivities begin
I love his ministry of silly walks walk
slapping his arms jungle should be back
Paul Alex
this music
[Applause]
I feel like we're in a Jean-Claude Van
Damme movie
no there's no guile yet
he'll be here
oh just got wrote wait we so we just saw
Alex by the dude in a ring and then
immediately cut away we didn't even just
what just happened they're just
reminding us that he exists okey-doke
hey birdie
was spotted above
and taken any action
but of course our family's satellite
read spun
dookie birdie looking a little bored
yeah one of the new characters added for
this DLC
they're added as part of the DLC yeah
and birdie new to the street fighter V
yeah it'll be really interesting to see
how both how uh how hunky controls
compared to who are in her incarnation
in four since this is really people's
first chance to play as her oh I get it
there watching Alex on the Giants that's
how they segue
[Applause]
thank you
wrestling
[Applause]
wrestlers in the house
I know Mortal Kombat has done did stuff
like that where it would make you fight
too dirty
yeah
we'll see we got Laura
stop thrilling at all
I mean the street fighter
we know
yeah I cannot remember her name oh man I
can't either somebody's got me though
Alex is just unfazed by all this yeah
they're like they're they're real Jazz
to be there Alex does not care at all
and we're back to Fang suddenly man I
really wanted to play I really wanted to
wrestle on that match why they gotta
take it away from me cut back it'll cut
back it already cut away and cut back
once I'm sure it'll do it again probably
man it'll be really interesting to see
how all of these Dory lines come
together because right now we're just
like it's just all the characters yeah
oh he took uh rasheed's little chess
piece yeah and he was like oh there's
only he only has one maybe
there are several more and in fact the
little grid you just set it in had more
spots so that will probably be something
that they revisit as part of this
narrative
also there's what's apparently the black
moon is that a thing I don't know about
or is that just part of the story I
think I think that's just like their
base is like the
oh there's their logo yeah well I mean
clearly was going to be a shadow yeah
assume it's like their Death Star yeah
destroyer of planets of some sort it's
got that vibe
[Music]
oh sad like watch out satellite no there
goes HBO or innocence satellite Game of
Thrones
oh it's Independence Day like the
original not a new one
[Music]
no way the server's down
little hideo Kojima moment there
no that's basically all Street Fighter 5
nowadays
not like was that a joke definitely was
about some of these
the game experience at launch and
arguably still experiences for many
players
it's better now though it's better
than it was
that is disorienting
Strong high altitude electromagnetic
pulses
I eventually guess that is the cause
oh I guess that was Sean playing the
little Capcom uh handheld yeah I didn't
even notice it because
did you always have the dreads I don't
remember I don't think so but I'm fairly
certain I wanted to say but I didn't
want to sound like I'm just typecasting
all Brazilians
I'm pretty well I mean there's only a
limited number of characters so like who
else is going to be really
no estimate on recovering power Black
Moon went off over a wide area damaging
these seven parts of the city as a
result we've lost all Communications in
those areas
this is a magnetic pulse caused by a
high altitude explosion
they did not adjust the mouse movement
to match the English style that's that's
fine I like this Army General
he kind of looks like a dude from the
Village People
he's got like the mustache to the
missing hackers incident
who it is you always show up with such
perfect timing
it's almost scary
your mission is to go to New York and
determine if there is any connection to
the missing hackers
I'm coming with you guys all right
generators coming on
America
much appreciated in China
it's my pleasure
she's not quite as patriotic she doesn't
have her national flag tattooed on both
arms
little Vega Cameo there
all wrong
all right
so what happened to the other
ever tell you that you have the
attention span of a five-year-old
I've already told you that the other
control keys were stolen by that
programmer
but since I took quick actions to
recover one of the keys I've destroyed
all this City's electrical functions
Congressman I might say
speaking of which what were you two
doing all this time I was working so
hard
you were in charge of this plan
and it was you who let a programmer
steal the control keys I would say
that's a huge disgrace
it's obvious who should be taking the
blame for this
cautiously when you dare say such
insulin things to me
I successfully enacted operation chains
the fact that the programmer escaped so
easily is all because you two are
incompetent
how dare you dissension among the Rings
who's fighting whom here
nope yeah killing each other
this is delicious
[Music]
stands for no tell me the courage too
many words
yes Lord over here
Two Soldiers have been able to gain
strength from your psycho power Lord buy
some dude it's the moral extension until
we get all the control keys back we will
spread more fear and despair
to you my Lord
just a couple of Puppets
what the hell are you doing oh please
don't be like that both of you why don't
you test them out at these ones
certainly two powerful Fighters like
yourselves are not prized by puppets
like them
already fools
bastard
all right who's gonna be
yes okay
another henchman the TV put some more of
a fight in the last guys also that was a
wild between fight oh that was a good
like maybe almost two minutes and this
fight just lasted about 12 seconds are
you are you a bell rug player or did you
just Crush that guy because he was
incompetent oh there you go there's
another one this guy's a little fat I
want to see what he does okay yeah
let's get a mid punch
so chunky
not really doing much
oh man that is healthy
not great it was stunned off two throws
good Lord
well
you piece of crap now it's your turn
smile must be here
[Music]
what's up guys it's just floating around
near
you guys
foolish to come here
know your limitations
pretty early in the interview fighting
after bikes I am bison oh you're by oh
yeah that makes sense that it's too
early for the heroes to try them
okay
all right
there we go man you haven't had to use
your V Trigger or like anything not a
lot of meter not a lot of creative arts
I think what someone in the Stream says
that after you beat it the first time
you can come back and play I guess more
difficult yeah it makes sense yeah
I've never played in five yet oh really
I really like it
away my
okay that worked
at the screen like the screen bounce
now it is time to finish
oh God someone's gonna intervene right
someone's got it or or they just come no
oh no Tammy
let's go Kyle
never actually
but bison will apparently
anyone anyone got a gun no okay
I think guns exist in Street Fighter
Universe yeah I guess not
there's no Onyx for the help
you after shadowloo
yes I followed them since the black
moons appeared shadowy was involved with
the destruction in New York
suddenly you completely lost your head
in that fight
I'm sorry I'll never act like that again
and what about the black moons
how do we stop them from going off
I'm not sure yet but it seems shadowy
doesn't have you look at that license
plate right there please don't let that
super what do you mean
certainly what it looks like
holes are stolen
someone betrayed bison or a spy
infiltrated shadowman look at this Vibe
you might have a
havoc and hackers
into incident
there's a group of computer hackers who
have gone missing
their ages genders nationalities all
vary
investigating this from all languages
such as a criminal organization was
behind it
to build the black
yes now we must stop the moons from
exploding
in the other six cities
take it easy
oh yes I need to ask something
this package an Interpol agent was
trying to deliver it to you before the
black moons appeared shadowloo attacked
him
whoever sent it as unknown
why the agent was attacked is also not
clear though I can guess
[Music]
same
everyone's got the same chess piece
that intro with the fire
cool guys slowly walking away from fire
hello my friends
stayed back
this might be true
glasses on usually they went so goofy
with Rasheed
he's like the comic relief I know
playing Charlie
I took over for Joey by the way so I'm
gonna be real embarrassed if I was real
bad here
especially against guile
oh
against Kyle it's like your rival man oh
okay I thought you meant he was like a
low tier character
top tier in your heart yeah
I don't know any of Charlie's combos
boom
didn't look great but it was effective
it was all right yeah
whoa that's pretty sick
what oh you absorbed it
puberty fine you can keep ignoring me if
you want it actually makes it easier to
take care of this
I am Rasheed of the turbulent wind I
came here to take that piece just hand
it to me quietly
it's very theatrical way to ask for put
it in my hand
please understand that the peace is
important to me I must have it no matter
what um the voice acting don't hate me
for this
is yeah it's like it's I feel like it's
Hit or Miss though yeah
so you mentioned that your your Street
Fighter 5 experience is a little limited
right yeah I've spent almost no time
playing this we played a lot of the we
played a lot of four and four super but
so I'd know nothing about how to control
receipt but uh let's see this course
took a Ford kick is actually pretty cool
it kicks out a little uh
uh lower mid or high or does it matter
yeah like that one that guy okay I got
you
I mean as the game will just keep on
Switching characters on you so you
really have to yeah just it's figure it
out I feel like if you've never played
the game before it might be a good way
to kind of introduce you to all the
different characters by forcing you to
actually playism yeah it throws you in
the deep end so I mean yeah you have no
choice but to adjust and learn on the
Fly
turbulent wind
cut to where are we
um that castle from Castlevania
go
all this is making Rashida to be kind of
like a a rogue agent he doesn't seem to
be on anybody's side yeah
I think if I remember his story
correctly he's just after Shadow like on
his own ah
and Charlie has found him you
oh now I understand
you were also receiving similar
information
why do they keep ignoring me
are we supposed to know who she is by
the way I think there's someone in chat
that mentioned who she was I just don't
remember okay
this is mesh
one of our Associates
who's tracking pieces your tracking
pieces but why would you want them
he has no interest in the
P plans to fight against bison so he
doesn't want them to get into shadowless
hands
oh it's jury
you're surprised
[Music]
so those are your personal toy soldiers
they look kind of dim to be Fighters
so if you're that confident then let me
try them out let's see
good
how about you
what's up why does nobody ever listen to
me
oh my goodness awesome stay back
somebody guess I'm gonna be jury
foreign
costume because it's pretty sick it's
definitely new remember in forms you had
like a business suit yeah oh no I'm
thinking of uh Crimson Viper sorry oh I
know she had the like it's like workout
pants and stuff like the white yoga
pants
oh that's new that was cool
like walk positions
this is this is so greasy by the way I'm
essentially button mashing and we're
just like crushing everybody
dude I want you to fight as him
yeah is that ever gonna be famous
the black moons
New York into chaos what if we could
stop them with these
what
you got a Christopher Robin in the chat
mentioning uh Jerry's moveset looks to
be pretty good yeah definitely compare
she's very acrobatic like compared to
Street Fighter 4's moves like I feel all
the characters that they brought from
four to five and they they slightly
modified all their moves to kind of fit
within the
to fit within fives uh you know gameplay
like mechanics and everything sure like
they make like these really minor tweaks
that seem like nothing or they take away
certain moves that you kind of Miss but
it it everyone seems to be working out
really well
they were missing reports about the
moons but yeah I mean to Echo something
that Peter said in his review
um I actually really appreciate that
they went for a smaller character roster
in order to make sure each character
felt totally distinct yeah that was kind
of the right approach and so far that
seems to have worked out or that seems
to have uh proven true that the
characters do you actually feel
different
linking those missing hackers to the
development of the black moons
the one who you seek is among them am I
correct
if so is n't it more efficient to all
work together
that makes sense
but if I'm going to risk my life for you
why don't you tell me who you really are
that point
I am really
oh of course oh durian putting together
secret plans in a place like this
Lord urine
so this is your precious clay dog
truly appreciate the support you
remember this guy
using the street fighter 3. I came here
third strike
do you playable character yeah wow I
mean it looks really different or what
memory is terrible in that game he was
not wearing any clothes
so this this is definitely a different
look for him okay
oh wow apparently he's playable and
we're fighting
oh that's sick okay
he's a Grappler type oh wow he has like
a little know what I'm doing he's like
ball
whoa oh that's awesome okay that's
really satisfying to listen here
oh well that's okay that works that was
not what I oh I wanted that fight to end
but sure
that was really quick that dude's
awesome I know he's not okay so both
Jerry and yurien they're in story mode
but they're not in the game yet like you
can't play as them in versus or online
or anything it seems inevitable that
they will become playable yeah they will
in this they'll just be balanced and
tuned I would assume and become fully
playable
oh the egg is reflector so aggro so
salty
gonna be
bursting out of his suit
did you know that your name is practical
urine
that's a seriously skin tight suit it's
like Taylor Made for his muscles yeah
crew looks really weird just hanging on
a on a hanger
it's all weird and wrinkly
because Sunday if I had a dollar for
every time
what
they're canned reactions are so great I
know
[Music]
on your third eye
it's a little weird what what you just
said was the truth she's really dead
[Music]
tried turning Charlie off and back on
again
[Music]
Staples for his face no
foreign
put together in the jungle or something
did wake up in a sarcophagus
[Music]
by
by more suitable to lead this world
that's why I want to destroy shadow
[Music]
s
I'm assuming we'll find out further
along in the story
[Music]
deadly plan
and to destroy bison
now
we are all comrades in arms
arms for at least
as long as bison still lives
there we're going to get back to Alex
because we never did end up fighting all
the wrestlers from the family ninjas we
also received the family niches
you are
oh you are exactly as Helen described to
me
that has this shape but I need you to
kindly give it to me
all right I'm taking the reins here
fight for it now can't we settle this
peacefully you must get what you want on
your own Merit
family motto
that was a funny little pause there
[Music]
I played him for like the first week or
so
foreign
yes they will
all right if you guys are just joining
us uh we are streaming the entire
cinematic story mode for uh Street
Fighter 5. it's just it just launched
today or earlier this week it actually
launched midnight today
I give up you have great fighting
strength as you can see it is very story
driven if I can see the ratio of like
cutscene time to actual fight times
probably
more than that I'm sorry but I'll never
use them for evil purposes you have my
word I don't know if you believe me or
not
but please believe me
that is not a great line but it's not
convincing at all
vasaki contact all the top ranked
fighters on the list and be using that
line from now on I don't know if you
believe me but please believe me
please
hey back to real all right
he outside that same Temple where
Charlie woke up oh it looks like it I
hear the waterfall
hey what's up bro
it's raining
[Music]
the Ryu can match up bring it on
so you're gonna be real well probably
Ken right yeah let's begin
still hanging on
ice
yeah they're not the AI uh opponent's
not real big on blocking in this mode
not a lot at all
nice offense there
it's real close
you're one of kanzuki's ninjas
what do you want
shadowless using the black moons to
drive the world into chaos
the kanzuki family is requesting help
from the world's best fighters to
prevent this from happening
we hope that you both will join our
cause
understood
I alone will join their fight for now
please tell them so
what the
you need to continue your special
training
but I
what I'm trying to say you need to
appear at the end of the story to save
the day
but in exchange
will fist bump when you complete your
training
you must show me the result of all your
efforts oh come on I knew it fist bump
sure
it's a very picturesque fist bump
see ya
I look forward to hearing about the
answer that lies Beyond
42.
it's the answer to all of life's
problems
[Music]
where did these two work together
I think they're just visiting the estate
oh they're part of the top fighters
they're getting recruited okay I get it
I get it your resources find any
information
as of now we were able to acquire a
master list the list of all people that
pieces was sent to
additionally we're currently
investigating who else might have
accessed that list
and what have you found out
the black moons
created by Shadow using the hackers they
supposedly kidnapped
pieces were likely made by the hackers
additionally guile is contacting our
colleague who infiltrated shadowloo we
hope he has more information to share
working undercover that sounds
interesting
if that's the case then shattaloo wants
these pieces and we must not let them
have it
we'll begin our operation when we hear
from Kyle
Capri
he's in here
oh I didn't hear about this
I'm not gonna play as her are we uh
probably no that'd be pretty sweet
did they mention this at all June
and down
[Music]
I hope my last words are Lord bison
I'll Never Let You Escape
if the two of you are not satisfied
fighting each other then I can join in
to give the satisfaction you deserve
oh thank you
I think you'll pass
be satisfied
oh that's what they're called dolls
thank you hata
forgot
I mean you you could chase her you
thought about it
yeah just better for the story just let
her go
control device recognizes the piece its
program can be activated
but more importantly the same pieces can
be used to activate their shutdown
program
anything else to report
shadowloo has the same list they'll be
going after them
them
all the good guys are here what's up
everybody has finally got it Avengers
Assemble
oh my according to the list one of the
pieces should have been sent to you I
remember I'll received some literacy
I was busy on the wrestling tour so I
left with friends
can you say where your friend is now I
think he's always the best
I will go and get I'm going with you
then who else has one
one was sent to a wrestler in New York
and a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu artist
New York transportation and
communication systems are all
inoperative
so I will go I guess that's because you
can fly I'll go with you I guess Cami
can come along too
what about you
I'll take Ibuki and Mika to the
shadowloo base we'll take the initiative
by scouting the area
good huddle team and break
[Music]
oh I forgot he has a family wait what
weren't you supposed to when did that
happen
I know he had a wife all right I promise
that when you can do a weird looking kid
we'll go together
why is he dress like PeeWee Herman
awesome
daddy is away
you'll have to protect your mommy
[Music]
it's nice to watch them play
I think Ken shouldn't have to come with
us
[Music]
he has a family he should stay here and
protect them
we're getting some deep family issues
right now got real tender and emotional
and that soundtrack
my father was the same way
[Music]
I'm sorry I didn't mean to remind you of
bitter things
it's just just one
families
confuse me I don't have one it's a real
tear jerker here
guile and the others have already left
I'll be leaving shortly with Ibuki and
Mika
I'll see you all again next time at the
base
all right and we're still at the house
[Music]
let's pull for a big guy
don't fall for it are you sure about
that
I feel where her gauntlets are from they
look super cool
no how do you hurt
sorry can you stand
good Let's Escape
you're not going anywhere
if I let you get away from me if you
escape back off
if you escape they won't feed me anymore
I saw her just throws something out
let's see if she'll do it again yeah it
was like weird
the first sort of unique movement out of
one of these kind of characters
it's not gonna last for very long
thread like their health engaged
generals
like chunks of Health
there's definitely a bit of armor this
is more challenging yeah yes I burned my
meal
[Music]
I never was angry
poor birdie
next to Sean
give me back my gaming device that is
legally distinct from my Game Boy yes
to my question
it's made by Capcom oh yeah
head in octagonal Direction my sister
has it you are correct
try to tell you where the control key is
or door number two where I take you
hosted and friend your sister
I made it just in time
are you all right
come on
yeah I wonder if you can just project
how spam your way right here
[Music]
you can
go to the corner then so easily every
time
[Music]
all right well you seem to projectiles
do anything about that
this machine the fights are so easy
because it makes it like we're just kind
of watching this very odd movie yeah
it's intermittently interrupted
by short-lived battles
dude
oh I want one of those
are you all right
wait I think I know you you're part of
the matsuda family yes I am
can I ask you was this sent to your
house
those guys were asking me about this
just before
so ah my sister I think she caused
trouble again
look could you
possibly give the peace to us
hmm
okay you guys saved my life but it's my
sister's
I happen to have it here watch out
what's up guys just come flying in huh
who is that
Laura
[Music]
are you guys talking about me
why is he so afraid what are you doing
around here
I know what it is
here yeah right
no you must eat more meat otherwise your
girlfriend won't like you he said I
don't have a girlfriend
you should stop them
let's make things burn with one more
head rub is this considered a typical
brother-sister relationship
that I've said hello
[Music]
Ken Masters I recognize who you are why
would a famous person like you be here
well
I was looking for a package that had
been sent to you you told Sean to give
you something I don't like the sound of
that if you're trying to steal from my
brother I'll make you regret it that was
a turned on a dime there man
now I'm here to collect all right that
was quick uh all right I apparently
you're fighting now
big fighting games probably there's way
more than I do he is halfway across the
world
don't play a lot Laura
come on
she actually have like capitas
thing
dude you don't be sick there was a block
of candy on here somewhere we are in
Brazil currently
I think right
I feel like they would have put them in
somewhere
still has the ability to fight even
after all that he is harada's favorite
from what I remember oh no oh no sorry
yeah
Dairy sorry
my bad
is that the case
to more is the same eighty percent of
your fights are because of
misunderstandings
pretty much
sorry about that in return for saving me
can I give them this okay
is here along with you he's in the game
his name's Laura matsura you just saw my
skill so if my skill can be of help can
you let me promote matsuna Jiu Jitsu by
using your online karate class deal
my thoughts exactly
besides I think you already decided
certainly just summarized our entire
feeling about this whole experience
taller or popular with girls I don't
need that just so you know your fighting
style is no longer matzah Jiu Jitsu what
are you
doing are you a friend of those stupid
jerks unfortunately you're a little too
just stay back this monster is too much
for you to handle
she is very presumptuous no
[Music]
oh here we go oh never mind
oh that was disappointing
well I guess they found
zengey's friend
got the piece back already
who was his friend who knows that's what
I would like to know
apparently not ball Rock
now
the doll here
oh it's through a spear at me there she
we'd see weapons in a Street Fighter
game well I guess if it functions as a
regular projectile yeah
it's really weird that several of the
dolls are just like
straight up ethnic stereotypes
it's like a flight attendant's outfit
plus ethnic stereotypes it's a little a
little weird
[Music]
again not much of a fight there
we're slowly seeing like oh she has a
monkey I guess apparently we're slowly
seeing different like abilities come out
from all the all the random ass
characters here yes I mean still
obviously not much of a challenge
right in the chest hair
some pile drives here this is your first
uh time controlling Genki right
it's a little Flex on him
for the record Joey nodded
yeah do that just chop him to death oh
nice that'll probably oh no didn't
finish him
their health is so weak I sort of assume
that would do it
trying to do a little
well
ugly but effective
they actually I played balrogs
individual story mode before I did this
this whoever this person is
I think his name was like Ed
it no idea better be right
Eminem
like a gym rat boxing dude like he's
supposed to be like balrog's Corner man
or something oh but apparently he's got
like weird Shadow was he hiding it in
his chest hair it definitely seems like
it just lifted straight oh my God that's
really
bizarre and funky and hilarious it's a
good place to put it sure
I think it's much gesture all the time
who doesn't
back to New York where I guess Alex now
is for some reason changing a tire
city is still in Ruins
oh that's right they talked about this
back at the compound that he you know
because Dawson New York is all jacked up
that's right
ooh two more continues to be right
another fight based on a simple
misunderstandings
shirt a turban
and rubber limbs
you're a very odd looking mugger I feel
like you would probably want to be less
conspicuous if you were a Mugger
floating away
I'll teach you to misunderstand me
he got you down below half Health though
it's getting closer
a Mugger with a human skull necklace
this happens all the time in San
Francisco
I am truly not a mug
what I would like to ask you to give
that peace there's some great lines out
of this story mode
Alex live in a trailer
I guess he just
travels around wrestling across the
country wrestling wherever he finds
finds a match
ah that thing's not a big deal to me the
sojourning wrestler
one last
deal sometime in the future you might
feel that you want to seek answers when
the time comes you must turn your eyes
to the world
thanks for being so vague all right man
that's cool
Joey have you ever turned your eyes
towards the world
if I knew what that meant yes
I think we should fight her to find out
quick misunderstanding no
we'll have we all have time to talk
we just know
care of her no don't
I'll fight her to be served but there we
go
I mean given that your only way of
interacting with this world is fighting
oh she's actually crazy
she's got the uh the crazy teleport
thing
oh that's really cool
Something tells me
I don't know it looks unfinished almost
like her teleports don't have any
effects on them
she just kind of like vanishes I don't
know into and out of existence I think
maybe that's to provide a tactical
Advantage because you you know if you're
actually playing someone online or
something you wouldn't want them to be
able to see where you were teleporting
to exactly yeah let's give capcom's
benefit of the doubt
uh I mean as you pointed at she's not
playable yet so it's entirely possible
they have more tweaking to do I don't
know if they'll even put her in the game
there hasn't been any Talks Of No but
again like just this is a fleshed out
character it'd be kind of surprising if
they didn't at some point
we have the authority to arrest her
take it easy
she's no longer a danger
we punched her a bunch of times
we should turn her over to them for now
your big sister will help you
we will help you
big sister
what are you doing give the girl to us
now
don't do it
she's always wanted a family
oh there is a gun see
they have guns
yeah oh my God this now suddenly makes
sense I was wondering what this was I'm
sorry I'm sorry Peter oh wow Peter's
Health gauge is not strong I just
murdered Peter absolutely broke his neck
he looks like Commissioner Gordon you
just murdered him
okay
oh Jerry
on a three-wheel motorcycle just run
over people with our bikes
she always had an eye patch am I insane
she had like a little whenever she would
activate her uh super right like a
glowing eye thing yeah
[Music]
oh there's they're cami's gauntlets
recognize them that's why because it's
the same gun that's the Cami has okay
follow them on foot it's foolish to do
that and it turns out their sister
straight line from here
right
again
are coming
I have to head to the base now
please hold them up sure riff Peter
leave it to me
oh you didn't have to fight those guys
a moment of silence for Peter yeah
I want to cut it down by my own hand
yeah that's cool vegan you just keep
doing you
I don't believe that I came back
by the way if you're just joining us for
whatever reason if you're just tuning in
we are playing all the way through
Street Fighter 5's new Campaign which
was added just today it's all obviously
very story driven tons of cutscenes it's
ridiculous ridiculous cutscenes we have
to find the control
that bison must be in here
find him and kill him
come on wait wait wait wait wait
just learned kanzuki and some other
people are coming here soon we all share
the same goal to stop the black moons if
we all work together our chances would
be better right
if we could stop the moon's license
power would all dude he's dead don't
even bother trying to talk to him
Zombie Charlie somebody please start a
street fighter cover band called the
black moons
anybody out there on these places all
the themes
or they just cover Guile's theme for 20
minutes at a time
all right we got one let's remove
good night guys
it'll be awesome if this had like kind
of Telltale style something story
decisions that you made and that would
dictate who you fight and you could like
align yourself with Shadow lures that
would be really cool I wish you had a
little more Direction here because as
someone in the in the chat just pointed
out it is a bit like an interactive
movie yeah
like have allegiances and oh
yeah right Street Fire Six coming yeah
2020. Ryu will remember that
so Mr Butler did you already find the
control room around here
who hope he gets a fight Butler head
Steward of the kansuki family
great then I suggest we should work
together and I'll forgive you for what
happened in the past please do not touch
my head Stuart
by the way do you actually have the
piece
again these guys are getting on my
nerves
[Music]
you're quite rude ASR you're with r
stand for although
ready for action
fighting I really just want to see this
his moves
[Music]
not have many moves
that's about we'd expect for like an
unnamed character though
yeah
like bacon fantasy saying imagine it's
Telltale Style game with Street Fighter
yeah because that's what I'm saying yeah
they just they just announced that
Batman one I think yeah and they've done
like the Borderlands like it's not
limited to their whole specialty is IPS
other people's ideas
I'm supposed to be responsible for their
safekeeping but there's no time can I
trust you
understood
it showed up they're just here now okay
I think they're in Shadow lose base
already
went there flow so they decided to leave
us behind
they finally gonna fight at some point
they're gonna
oh that guy's real dead straight up
murder
hey
[Music]
is this what you chunks are looking for
do you want it come and get it
hey buki I did her trials I don't
remember much
remember to sweep away
it's really cool limited number of the
uh
uh shurikens two knives too nice thank
you I couldn't think of the proper turns
um
that
hey balrog actually like reversed and
bunch of you the AI is like finally
stepping up at the game
use that bomb
[Music]
oh without knives but I still got it
that didn't work I feel the difficulty
breaking up slightly just slightly
don't worry compared to my special
training this is nothing
now why don't you try me on precise
[Music]
some good trash talk you're just a big
idiot
foreign
[Music]
death sounds are always pretty great
they got the piece certainly look like
it
it's a lot of work to play a chess game
please fight the butler
please fight four of these guys at once
that'd be awesome
yeah I'm getting slightly disappointed
that there aren't any new mechanics like
in the story mode yeah straight up
one-on-one matches
like one round a piece yes and really
nothing sort of interesting about the
gameplay format
neither you just teleport why is he
excuse me
yoga flame them that's why
you are one of the people who has the
marope
aren't you
so shadowloo was using hackers to track
all of the pieces down
we'll save the conversation for later we
have to get out of here now
[Music]
there's someone
I mean I still have to look for look for
Asher
yeah you know pop star of 2000 to do
so that means
I can't escape from here yet
[Music]
that girl what is she doing
man I keep seeing tons of articles of
clothing clipping through other things I
can basically every character
let me just knock those doors down oh
they certainly did
hey they made it to the chessboard
so we have all six of them
after we set up these pieces we'll be
able to stop the black moons
or will we
into my very important control room
what are you all doing in here
you must be exhausted after your trip
I think this is like the fourth or fifth
fight
and also fangs
you only play the bad guy now
oh no
actually it would let you control Fang
and win and then it would be Changi
versus Spang and you would control but
apparently not
hey still I'm using many of his
abilities just kind of crouching and
dabbing
stole cold stuff
oh you know Mika actually has that yeah
as one as one for reversals she does the
stunner the stoner the stoner it's so
good
back
this is it
people interesting we should be able to
fight that little girl
you know if we fought Peter yeah
seriously
Peter is the highlight of this whole
thing so far
also fangs temper tantrums are pretty
amusing
they're very big sleeves
the sleevious sleeves
it's so missile silo
their main headquarters
oh
there's gonna be Exposition grunt number
four
no it's able oh what the [__] they this
is also was not teased
also I don't know why he's wearing like
a German Helmet oh he was trying to
losing a shadow Lube he's trying to
infiltrate or something what I remember
about his character he has like crazy
Amnesia though right yeah so maybe he
just forgot that he signed up for this
maybe
a minimum piece of French amnesiac who
knows how to wrestle right now or else
[Music]
do you think I'm a complete fool who
didn't realize who is Roofing around for
the ones who have the control keys
tell me do you want me to melt you down
like I did to that other programmer
The Descent program
with this nobody will be able to stop it
from happening
stop what from happening
um the destruction of the world that's
what it always is that's that generally
seems to be there
Despair and hatred
Lord bison will be the one to rule the
world
hahaha
I mean he is really loyal to bison I
know well he's the number two man
what did you say Yeah we actually did
get to play as urian earlier
oh so many chats yeah yeah
you gotta be awesome you got to play him
for one match and it was a really short
match it looks really cool
I wish we could just jump to a certain
point in the campaign so we could Replay
that section I think you can oh really
okay yeah like after we finish it gotcha
I guess we'll find out we got to be
getting relatively close to the end I
suspect I mean maybe it's hard to gauge
well they have a timer now yeah we're
like they're we're at the main base like
the timer thing only 24 hours left right
so we finish this
isn't good
can't be
oh
power
oh you're gonna have to fight Abel
he's been possessed
my aura is purple
oh there's bison okay yeah we're
definitely getting close to the end
bison started
there we go rule of Destruction
Whirlwind of Chaos
that gives bison all his power
then I'll finish you here
get in there
well I've never expected that you're a
lost soul would stumble its way back to
me
kill you
it looks like you want to die
you wouldn't hit a guy in glasses would
you oh no yeah bison here oh okay and
they give me full meter and B trigger so
uh yeah I think they want me to win I
think so it seems like every match
actually you start with at least a whole
B trigger
no yeah I didn't think so I was like I'm
not crazy uh yeah so they they really
want you just go for it I guess you guys
really have a single round so you really
have time to build up for the reader
because everything just go super quickly
oh I should have waited
okay again Charlie's way more of a fight
nice it's kind of nice it's actually
yeah
oh okay what happens this is the first
time we've lost a match
okay let's try again oh and it literally
just you start over wow okay yeah the
consequences were losing not very
serious which I guess fair enough it's
not it's I mean it's a story mode but uh
yeah
the Joey Bob Jones in the chat is giving
you a hard time for losing
whatever Bob Jones hey
is Nash we're talking about he's a ghost
or he's a zombie thing not yet
do you think the Feast of Someone Like
You One whose life has already inspired
can even reach me
never lose to a dead guy
all right
this is where Ryu steps up
these oily dreads
all right why do they make them make
them do that I don't know
I've been waiting
that guy's always saying though what was
it I've been waiting for you what
because you don't want to make it seem
like you're surprised so you just say oh
I've been expecting you or like
falling right into my trap even if they
don't have any plan whatsoever that
sounds about right yes
also somebody else knows that like those
little girls will sit in that chair back
there like not really just chilling I
feel like you should probably Escape at
this point well everyone's distracted
and faint is no longer like holding his
weird little claws in front of him
did I miss the part where they explained
why nikali is fighting and bison aren't
they both like bad guys are they bad
guys independently
I'd be great if they mentioned it I may
have just been making stupid jokes a
little bit so then again I I feel like a
lot of the estimations
also in the colors
get out of here oh God don't lose don't
lose
oh I apologize hey we're getting to the
it's we're getting to the end you want
me to uh
a few rounds
making fantasy wants to know how all of
these people are getting into the secret
base that's a very good question
security was lacks today relax and also
apparently everybody knows where the
secret base is all right not releases I
think I'm done for it uh also yeah
ass wow dude he just he's a critical
Lord
this escalated very quickly as soon as
we got to the base also I'm probably
gonna lose two because I don't say that
well I mean I don't really know how to
use bison at all he's never been my
character but I haven't played much of
five so well you just you just did this
and let's get hit whatever works yeah
that'll do it cool well that was kind of
lucky I didn't expect it to hit but
awesome oh
oh
walking oh my god oh and I'm not
guarding it all
right
started so strong and I'm totally gonna
fail
oh yeah I mean it's all right
it's not a battlefield win or lose it's
about how cheesy the story mode ends up
being
people are pretty cheesy
oh no so uh so
and chat buddy GTV is asking if it's uh
if it gets better or worse than the
Mortal Kombat games uh and honestly I
actually haven't played them I have like
yeah I've been mostly a street fighter
guy but from what I've heard they've
always been very uh like extravagant and
just like weird oh yeah they're super
weird
um I mean no less weird than how this
has been the one thing I will say as
I've been saying I'll stream I'm sort of
disappointed that all the matches here
have been just straight up one-on-one
matches you haven't had to fight like
multiple enemies in succession or
anything like that it's been interesting
to fight seems like Peter the cop I
should focus on not dying
um but I do wish they'd done something a
little more with the Canton mechanics or
like just the basic setup of the fights
yeah that's just throwing you into like
single round one-on-one matches over and
over
um because this was an opportunity to do
something a little more different which
is something that Mortal Kombat has done
pretty consistently in their new
campaigns so it's a shame that they
didn't get a little more adventurous
with that portion of it
um so it's hard to say which one's
better or worse I think it's a matter of
taste this is certainly like funnier uh
because the Mortal Kombat ones are
always really boring gruesome so this is
a little more just kind of like
light-hearted and silly and enjoyable
um but it's a shame they didn't do more
with the mechanics all right I'm gonna
try this one more time if I fail I'm
gonna make the joke
I'm gonna call uh
we've got some really excellent Street
Fighter players in the office and
they're all busy so you're stuck with us
oh yeah Richard Richard Lee uh our video
producer is an excellent Street Fighter
player uh Julio Park is uh our like
Facebook and social media guy he's
really great as well
they're just doing other stuff
you just you're just stomping all over
you it really is I'm completely blowing
it here oh
through every match does not being able
to beat nikali all of a sudden
there's no idea and yes uh Gucci That is
Scott who was just playing uh I am Joey
yeah yeah I'm gonna be taking the reins
right now in the off chance that you
were just tuning in I'm Scott
Butterworth one of the editors Joey
he's playing
we're playing through the entire
story campaign
Joey is currently trying to not lose
anything they're just gonna take it slow
yeah I think we can play conservatively
yeah we got so used to being able to do
whatever we wanted and not get punished
for playing sloppy but yeah when it's
suddenly that hard
what the hell
I'm gonna do the same thing to him
I thought you got this there we go oh
that's it yeah
glowy anime background
you know your place
in this game
I want a soundboard of all the different
insults
again things
it's not really that big a deal but it's
so noticeable
everyone's gigantic locks of hair yeah
where you going bro where are you going
it's like a predator right there
he engaged cloaking
oh good sir oh my God
the camp is unreal I really like what
they made Rasheed like this total comic
relief character
well it had to be someone and you can't
always rely on Zangief I think we did
get that one good Zangief moment there I
wish there was a little more you mean
the chest hair yeah the chest piece and
the chest hair
oh I see
I guess they still haven't finished the
job
damn it
still wasn't able to find my friend yet
an old friend it's hard to find a friend
his friend was a bit of a bone Little
David bazan reference for all the emo
nerds out there with line anybody huh
nope okay a lot of companies were making
job offers my friend was hesitating to
make a decision but then suddenly
decided to work for a company that was
under shadow
probably was tricked into it after all
would ever end up making the black was
it was he did he work at a catering
company or something I think I think
he's making mistakes he's saying that
his friend built the black moon but for
some reason it cut to the cafeteria
right there so he was like a he was like
a contractor or something like that
I think we're talking about quality
dialing here sorry everyone did I get a
single thank you what a friend
all right
this time I think it's very serious
then I assume
he will continue looking
good sir
he is pissed he is again
[Music]
no fight cutting away
bookies in a school uniform that's a
weird nude costumes I guess you just
never had time to change or she left her
clothes her ninja clothes
oh yeah
what do you think
zonkeyf all right yeah they pronounce
his name weird in the game
or maybe correctly maybe correctly yeah
uh gang's all here now
yeah
what's up with the logo on the side of
the helicopter
oh
jagged
he's not in his right mind we have to
snap him out of it I'm beating his
brains in
I'm stuck I actually really like April
he was one of my favorite videos really
good uh so I'm glad she can show up I
doubt he'll be like playable right now
but this implies that someday
[Music]
I really like that they're his fan club
adorable
that was a nice job however you need to
develop a lot more muscle power oh
that's a problem you didn't actually get
to fight him I really wanted to see
Abraham
yeah that was really anticlimactic I
wanted to actually fight him come on
everyone hurry
understood did John ketchup mentioned
the Army because window
also Mighty sandwich had a really great
theory in chat which is maybe El Fuerte
found work at the Seattle area oh so
she's like a chef right he like has a
ladle so are you saying that rasheed's
friend is huerte maybe that'd be pretty
sick
he like talks about like cooking like
all his like smack talk in Street
Fighter 4 is always like yeah I played
him so much in four he's a fun character
like this weird little like Dash thing
yeah that thing's so fun
come on dead man
nobody's trying to help him
oh never mind
he's gonna let go
that's what the camera angle implies oh
nope he made it
[Music]
oh wow this campaign's gonna keep going
because I thought we were gonna wrap it
up no well we got one more day
oh that's right yeah the Doomsday clock
is ticking
I forgot about these these three
they ride that motorcycle from Brazil to
London yeah pretty sure there's an ocean
in between there
[Music]
but we have the same hair
looks like she'll never be cured why
don't you just kill him
is it like a Bioshock or not a mass
effect like biotic power ooh sword yeah
she got like blades in there somehow
that was weird
hey which way to platform nine to three
quarters guys
everyone's just showing up where
everyone else is yeah they're really
good to keep track of each other
also the bad guys have the craziest
fingernails
I think maybe it's just a shadow uh it's
like a part of the uniform yeah
give them all these little fake nails
dude Megan how's that your mask what
about your face
beautiful face
he is pretty beautiful
beautiful memories
cut my tongue
you fancy said uh
they took the motorcycle but Vega ran
from Brazil
yeah he was at a rooftop in Brazil oh so
I guess he must have followed them here
so that explains what he randomly shows
up uh but yes he probably apparently he
just ran
into a train station
such a good friend
sorry I'm distracting you while you're
fighting now I'm looking at the
background sorry sorry I'm about to be
stunned I'm trying to spot a TARDIS
get out of there
you lost your claw dude I got oh there
you go
oh
I love that move that was that was
definitely a carryover from four oh no
oh this is looking bad dude
I feel like their um Health gauge has
become stronger like that's the biggest
change yeah it's a lot more to actually
kill them now
like not only are they actually fighting
bats okay wow
coupled with the fact that I've never I
haven't played Vega until now right all
right if you lose one more I'll I'll
give it a shot okay no I know Vega from
four
let's hope
I still got the slide
I don't want to jinx it but you're
looking pretty good oh okay
oh Jesus
Emmy is super fast
is that yeah I think that's it yeah okay
so I kind of froze there for a second
that was weird
oh that's right they changed not a
charger okay I would not know how to use
bacon then
like I remember they got rid of charge
moves on most characters except for like
and bison and Fang those might be the
only two in balrog I guess
she
did you lack delicacy
so go back home and then cry in your
pillow
oh jury time yeah
see if she still has the same move
this might be the first time there's
been a direct like you fought as
somebody and then the very next round
you fought against them I feel like it
hasn't happened at least often so far
so that's kind of interesting
nice counter thereby yeah I'm getting
weirded out by her her uh little effects
like her smoke Trails or something
oh look that was some good smack talk
just she just went annoying
oh
[Music]
my sandwich Guile's also a charger all
right all right
in case people are wondering what chat
we're reading we're currently looking at
twitch uh we don't have a huge monitor
so that's when we have open current
the aggressive strategy seems you're
working out just like walking right
again oh damn
oh yeah that's pretty sick okay yeah
also once again we're playing through
the entire Street Fighter 5 story
campaign if you're just joining us there
are a lot of cutscenes
we're about how far maybe about two
close to two hours in playing almost two
hours yeah
he's Joey I'm Scott this is Game Spot I
say playing about 15 watching cutscenes
for about an hour and 45. seriously we
should have been counting how many
actual matches there I know
because there's been quite a few but the
early ones just flew by there was like
no challenge that's new her pinwheel is
a dragon punch motion huh
gotta remember that next time I'm
allowed to play as her
really empty train station
who all right
every scene is a cliffhanger
also there's a Doomsday Clock ticking so
we're going back to our own Hideout now
it seems Helen already has some new
information
oh able still able
still around her head yeah
if they did load him into the chopper
with them
why
you know the purple Aura is kind of
messing with him
here
what is happening
giving them his memories it's like a
Vulcan mind meld or like what's
happening
what the hell is going on
sucking out the purple
can do
you okay do you know who I am
you're the one
stop my madness
merci beaucoup
that means thanks a lot
Charlie
take this you forgot this
damn heavy does he remember now
wait we didn't fist bump
okay
really oh that turkey popped in but a
little late
share with us
I see everybody's here
I forgot about her so you said there's a
way believe that is Helen
oh there is a way
yes
but it depends on you
and if that person
I found a command
right up the pathway for those who stray
I call thy name
cryptic
none of us can kid
[Music]
you just say their name come on
it seems like a code I assume you can
decipher it
with Rasheed of the turbulent wind
I thank the developer of the black moons
and your friendship with her it's Kismet
the command is act
ual whose plan will come to know
I'm very excited
of course
you can only do what is in my ability to
do
pray that I won't be able to end bison's
life
don't say things like that
strength to do that however
don't say that
don't you know how much I had to
sacrifice just to bring you back to life
when you can't win you are supposed to
win if you win with the power given from
my loved on the prophecy but I'm already
dead
dead men time will stand soon but
bison's psychopower keeps growing and
evolving whereas I have
if you get frightened and decide to
chicken out
all right I'll tell you something
your tiny shorts just for a limited
period by the grace of my Lord
the Lord of Light tell me you actually
thought you would live forever
I'm still very confused at some parts
there is no next time for a few days
thank you
I know that already
what did you say
I know I don't have much time
so I have to do what I have to
hey wait up
my big question is who is her Lord
exactly is she like some kind of Russian
Satanist or like what's going on Lord
bison I don't think it's him but yeah
she seems to want Charlie to kill bison
so that would be a weird choice
drops
sweaty man can't help it see if you make
some more growling noises hey Reeves
back
hey there's Rel noise
finally
[Applause]
just the cherry blossoms there what
happens wherever you goes
real time
uh yep sure enough different than before
twice
not really exactly at all though
I'm sure he's throwing a single punch
oh there's a kick oh come on
wow that was bizarrely easy considering
we kind of struggled through the past
couple fights
especially with the last one with with
bison against or maybe he's he got a
yeah biting it's neat
I messed them up then or you just back
stronger
[__] that was pretty sick
good like classic Kung Fu movie move
right there
[Music]
very Dragon Ball Z right now
the whole story has been so anime yeah
oh yeah
probably to like just punch him
watch
that look bad
damn butterfly he's so silly
you see melting
like the others
you must go
his soul is no longer a sacrifice for
you
he is melting I was totally kidding
let me go get the hose
just rinse off this uh this porch right
here
it's very manly nod
not quite well then we're going back to
the shadowloo base
National I just received a report
they believed they found a way to stop
the moons
that's amazing
and let's leave it to them to stop the
moons
will go there to defeat bison
I'll go with you
you certainly made us wait for a long
time then I'm sure you'll work twice as
hard
right
[Music]
two four six eight
don't forget all the other good guys I
wonder where they are let's get hero
post though it means you got the big
three Ken Chili Rio you know
Black Moon is still intact all of our
attempts have been ineffective
what's the current evacuation status
when all the cities are panicking not
even 50
.
it's time to stare that tiny hat
adorable tiny hat
foreign
[Music]
book says Testament is it supposed to
just be a straight up Bible
[Music]
the whole series is back
I heard about a fool who was bitten by
her
[Music]
it is
not done yet my Lord
[Music]
I'll be waiting for your good news
so Uriel the Lord that brought Nash back
is that what she's possible does he have
that kind of power I don't know that
much about his character I I don't
remember it did not cover that
I mean I feel like a lot of the game or
a lot of the story mode just kind of
expects you to know the story from
because this takes place between Street
Fighter three and four
so
there's a lot that we're missing Maybe
it is entirely possible
you're going to wait until I stop the
moons okay
are you guys serious wow oh something
controlled oh no there was one fight
you play battleborn do they have a
parachutes off no they don't they're
just jumping out of him
there's no fall damage to Street Fighter
uh
uh where look at some more textures
my team will handle this thank you
it's the doll
psycho power
Sideshow Bob best of luck
same to all of you
what
decided that I shall be your opponent
today is this gonna be our next fight
you should feel oh it looks like it
nope
Psych
it's really weird when it builds up like
there's gonna be a fight and then you
know it's so it does it several times
okay
can you grab it
oh wow
dude okay that was probably the best
part of this this whole story mode right
here that was great
though
nice spinning pile driver right off the
bat yeah look at you go
no remorse
almost got a double area
it's much faster than you she has some
cool moves yeah
yeah I was actually I was really
surprised when I found that out I love
that I think that's a great choice
even it makes having real life even more
exciting I think because you can still
you still get them oh yeah
uh
feels like a Chain Grab
[Music]
yeah
oh it has like a little bit of startup
but it's pretty cool
he has like a bunch of grabs
I got it
okay mighty sandwich reminds us that uh
super chip can kill if you chip with a
super kill them but like for normal
moves they they don't which is nice
oh actually you're
probably not gonna matter here
oh Jesus I didn't mean to end it like
that that was so pathetic
whatever
that's not what I was trying to do
the pig is a bird
oh
loves those donuts I guess the others
might be in danger
I guess it's time for me to get out of
here quickly
oh
they're still standing there they are
can't decide if he's trying to do like
Jason Statham impression his accent is
so like it's kind of Muddy yeah
the last
so care to say your prayers
that was pretty sick
that's what I want to see more of or
would have liked to have seen more of
totally
all the school that we're getting these
kind of like custom like proprietary
characters who are like oh look at that
oh wow that was cool I mean I'm getting
my ass kicked but up getting math kicked
in a very cool way
s
all right
wow okay I want another chance at that
that was pathetic
[Music]
yeah there we go
oh she's almost at Stone
there we go nice
[Music]
foreign
this could be a fight oh okay
no
Julie
yeah again opposing of these dolls in
the uniform manner they're known to Cali
that that dude's way harder to fight
Folly yeah whatever
Julie hype
honestly definitely I don't know what's
going on anymore either and I'm the one
playing we're the ones playing
there's some moons that are gonna
devastate some cities and the originally
they were collecting a bunch of chess
pieces giving up on that and everyone
who needs anyone else will just fight
them without talking there's a lot of
misunderstandings not like people being
possessed uh apparently I'm Vega I
thought it was still going to be candy
but I'm in Vegas so that's not a great
way to start that fight
[Music]
really weird I'm trying to do stuff from
foreign
[Music]
well
that was that was bad not bad at this
game I'm do one more and then if I lose
them all right
even the pressure on her at least
[Music]
all right
got the life lead right here
foreign
[Music]
not the motorcycle
I'm gonna get home now
invite me especially if you guys are
having
why
seems like she wants to help you
let's have fun together
uh nope
I didn't I didn't think I hit a button
but apparently I did
once again secret base very easy to
infiltrate
they just let anyone come in here
in case you're just tuning in we're
playing all the street fighter 5's new
campaign mode this is Game Spot I'm
Scott that's Joey we've said that a
bunch of times but people keep tuning in
and out so hey it's us again what's up
guys
oh calm down she's literally just saying
exterminate
she has psycho power mind control right
but it's weird that she's the Doctor Who
character
like all of his moves are pretty pretty
fun to watch at the very least it's fun
to play
I could actually land these grabs
fine I'll just like ship you away in the
corner it's gonna be like that reason to
block all the fun stuff
ah all right I love when he backs up
come on
oh okay
that's pretty weak that was right
Sailor Mars yeah it's ripe annoying one
this must be it
27 minutes really pushing it here
did that code say SF or se4
um he knows what to put you always had a
flare for the obvious when it came to
puzzles
pretty weak
but I guess that's wrong
well no it's great
look at them shut down beginning
sequence to stop all functions
I love his little icon
you think Fang would have figured out
what they're doing by now I
coming in here and there's someone
different in here every single time you
think he would just stay put or lock the
doors
My Friends final piece of work
steal the control keys for the moons but
terrible thing like this
knew that I should have killed that
we're still not supposed to know who
they're talking about right I don't
think so again
what did you say
I poisoned and ended the life of your
very very dear friend that's what I said
foreign
style like he's gonna get thrown down
the pit I hope so
I get him
but doesn't do much damage but it looks
real cool
there we go
throw all of the wind at him try it
out didn't even good
that was really easy too why did it get
hard right in the middle go back to
being really easy
oh skull phone
I have finished my friend now you can
rest
like a cheap shot we'll finish you off
for sure
you know Rasheed you still need to be in
Street Fighter five
not like this as long as Lord buy some
leaves
the world is destined to become hell
don't you find peace in
pieces and now
my phone
it's always a bummer when your phone
shatters
I think we can all relate to Fang right
now
his power has disappeared
where am I
foreign
but still it's not too late
I will never forgive you
a defective don't like you should talk
to me like that we play as her or Fang
I'm guessing Fang
just let her win
oh [__] well
well match them there's no way it'll
alter the ending oh that's kind of cool
you're with the bad guys to win well I
mean
somebody like a name after this also
Fang is still really weird I don't know
how to use this character yeah he's a
Charged character all right as soon as I
die I'm gonna let you okay
this
[Music]
she has a laptop
oh man I'm sure I'm sure captain on a
lot of fun like designing these random
ass characters yeah which is awesome
it's nice to see them have fun it's cool
that they incorporated characters like
that and weren't like the main
characters yeah
another another frequent line
nope she's hanging in there
I'm just taking him down yeah Star Wars
oh maybe not
oh it's melting the edge
you live no no no not yet I'm too young
I can't die yes
uh wow all right
you can officially never play Fang again
not disabled from the game from now on
just a little more so don't interfere
I'm gonna fight this Rasheed again right
now oh nope oh that little girl's still
in the chair
Professor X like I don't get it
even more dogs
poison
I'll end this right here
you never realized we haven't played as
Chun Li
that's a good point yeah we haven't
there was one fight this guyo really
early on
a couple fights is for you but yeah no
chubby fights weird
yeah I would I would be super
disappointed from one of the random
ninjas just like just cut bison down and
it just ends yeah that's come on that's
clearly not gonna happen
looks like Charlie's gonna get another
crack at him now
oh it's the end it's just the uh yeah
that's pretty cool
I love the stage
I like the Incorporated Incorporated it
into the
nice touch
no matter how many times you come back
you'll never win against my psycho power
perhaps
but I will achieve my victory
then why don't I send you to hell so you
can collect
the victory that you're desperately
looking for
didn't totally makes sense
wow okay yeah
oh okay wow hey Joey you want to try
this I'll try it all right
not that great with Nash but okay
right out of the game
the pendulum has swung back in our
Direction like originally our attacker
powered up compared to what they would
be in the wake of the game but now
opponents charged up
also you're doing better than I did
it kept me over
here you already can't
yeah
got it
I will figure out
uh I don't know
oh that was sick though
[Applause]
pretty much
I don't know I feel like that's a good
point I haven't been thinking about this
as a as a competitive game at the moment
maybe I'm at a coach I don't know how
people are getting competitors
are pretty
pretty well I think all right
yeah oh that was pretty it was a good
finisher too yeah I think what most
people were disappointed with five was I
guess just the lack of content how
incomplete is that it's like a
connectivity problems so a lot of the
people who aren't really into Fighters
they saw it and they were like why would
I even spend 60 on the game with such a
little content
but the people who are really into fine
games they saw the great mechanics and
how like balanced it was yeah yeah and
so I think it was a good introduction
for a lot of people but it it it's gonna
take a little bit more time to really
get into it yeah well this update
no but you won the
one with Charlie no
no
bastard
huh
is he going to overwhelm him with like
The Power of Love or I want to see that
don't cut don't cut to Rasheed
well we we have to establish that he is
a
story save the world yeah
just 28 seconds to spare
time to play my last card that was so
weird why did you cuddle we should have
just stop it no we kind of we assumed
that like because the world hadn't ended
up always absorbing psycho power I think
yeah what are you today was funny joke
already dead it's still about reading
this
[Music]
one
of course
oh no well
his psycho Powers Yeah
yeah but wait there's more
Fang's still alive
somehow
a few times
I hope so believer's Fang
it's looking like it no come on okay
fine
it's an awkward hug
real get him
that's a dog
why you
why are you can you kill you can you
kill you
I've had enough of you
yeah
I still really want that trash box on
board
[Music]
[__]
although your health is defining it
isn't that yeah
[Music]
boom
again
I really don't know because it's been
we've gone back to like easy wins after
that
wrong
many times we have to fight Fang yeah I
think it's like the fourth or fifth time
at least yeah
I mean he's been a prominent character
in The Narrative but it's still like
okay we get it we [__]
even I had expected you are the one who
comes to me in all this chaos
you had the power to actually defeat
that Beast now show it to me
the power to push forward
a desire for all power leads to
leads to and that conflict needs to the
ultimate battle
now is the time
other cliches
I think
I got one
nice I'll do it out of here
oh God
oh my God
you got this
oh no
oh you serious
very close though
YOLO man dude guys this is the final
boss
we don't know that yet there could be
other like five more Fang fights after
this
bison in this chamber seems like it's
got to be the final income
foreign
[Music]
oh God
he's on vacation in the world of Tekken
yeah
oh yeah
I love that combo yeah
nice
look at me
that's not good oh man
You Wanna Give It One try let me go all
right
well this is a computer you gotta
remember right so he knows everything it
does
I can't predict that
oh that would have been nice
oh
yeah
go right over shellcaster experience
[Music]
after that
is nice
foreign
alrighty here you go oh man you might
have to go get a ringer
the Fang versus Fang final boss fight
yeah
okay that was ugly
okay
you [__] whoops I mean
go away
bison always has the pressure but it's
like
so okay well you have you have that oh
did you just bury him oh shoot come on
oh come on
I think I think the way to go about this
is just going ham
I wouldn't be so sure oh that had gotten
him I would have had him
dang it
combo
okay how did I do so on the last round
okay we might just be thinking a little
bit wow
this round is kind of a loss already I
came back from this
however if you wanted to use that at
some point
oh yeah
go and turn that on right now
I'm just gonna walk into that
all right one more and then we might
want to go get uh uh one of your yeah I
I know the person to ask Street Fighter
we have some Street Fighter experts in
the office way better than either of us
I mean Joey's pretty good
right now
come on
man if I don't connect
okay
seriously why couldn't we have gone
everyone in the cast to just be on the
screen at once again seriously
fear I'd walk it
well
we owned here I think so yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna go one more as you go grab
Julia or wait do you want to give him
more shot yeah I'll go grab Julia so we
can get him to help us out I'm sure
everyone in the Stream is judging us
very harshly for not being able to beat
this game this far guys come on
just uh you know really
I was gonna say keep it uh keep it
defensive
but when you can react just like on a
drop of a pin
[Music]
all right
today
tutorials
wow okay
it's going in then
What's it gonna do
life
I'm sorry Julio
all right so we got we got Julio in here
he's our social media guy
and uh
way better than mine so I think
yeah he will do every combo in the world
I speak
thanks
all right
how many times did you guys die
I think it was about 10.
[Music]
keep in mind this is the computer
smarted by not thinking at all
I think that's the way to go about it
oh boy
that's lovely
oh [__] he's almost at stun
[Music]
there we go
I won't hesitate
I I believe this is the very end of the
storyline since
bison versus Ryu did Nash fight bison no
he fought
oh no no he did he did like right before
this
but he's got ryu's Got The Power of Love
on his side
hey Julio Tay's calling you a scrub
hmm
people have been predicting it's Fang
versus Fang because we've fought him so
much in the story
there's some really good dialogue by
good I mean bad
this place is about to
thank you
let's go
foreign
oh man I love those gold gloves
[Music]
down goes bison's Laboratory
it's so weird like earlier on they
touched onions
and Cami talking about kins
kid
for like no reason other than to give it
some uh
yeah
they had to give Ken some part right
because otherwise he doesn't have a very
prominent story yeah they were like he
shouldn't be he shouldn't be going on
this mission
you should stay at home with his with
his child
who would call now just when I finally
get to relax
hello who is it
good job
who could it be
if you're listening to this message it
means you have successfully stopped the
Moon
surprised I
I can cool like this at least once the
monkey is the true hero I always
believed you would stop it
slap with a laptop yeah that one was
hilarious and then the the other doll
with the the megaphone I don't know if
you saw that one I didn't see that one
just like some megaphone combos
DLC characters
[Music]
going down
you never said anything like that to me
before
[Music]
well time to go
wow and that's it
no no it's a little bit there's a little
bit at the end dude don't spoil it man I
know I won't but I didn't want you to
press start or anything you know
there's a stupid butterfly
Shadow has been destroyed who's this
that was the river what's her name Helen
I don't remember I don't know who did
the butterfly land on the ending is
slightly different from from text
written in the ancient prophecy
oh I can't see him
take some gases becomes obvious can't
see his hair and he has no clothes
perhaps yeah what kind of character
wears no clothes
well murian usually
he has a suit in this one
the world is destined to be Ashen and
barren
the balance all right oh is that gill I
saw the blue in the oh man
don't tell me this is a tease for more
DLC
Seth well it could have been Seth
come and follow me
himself right
you can balance it probably yeah it's
too much
so she's really
this woman
thank you Ono for this
it was immensely entertaining yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
start out of it
there we go
do you think they fixed Ken's face for
this story mode a little bit actually he
looked a little different which was I
was surprised thank you for waiting
looks a little better yeah like his chin
especially he's spending a good time
still haven't changed at all
had three yeah six surgeries
the one you've been long searching for
I don't really play Ken so if I lose
everything
now I get it
I guess you won't be needing this
anymore huh
there is no end on the road of fighting
I know I thought it was going to give it
back to the canvas
story right yeah the headband
in Alpha Ken has the long hair oh yeah
that's right that's right he ends up
giving it to Ryu
H
that's it that's it
we only got 30 000 fight money for that
really oh oh man well it's all right
so I think we're looks like we're going
to try to jump into some uh
versus mode here
yeah we're gonna try out the new
characters and also the new costumes
possibly
and also there's a couple new stages
right
yeah there are but yeah
[Music]
yeah you're probably going to have to
get a stick from the cabinet right okay
so we'll actually we'll pause right here
we'll take a break after such a long ass
story mode thanks for watching uh we'll
be right back here
[Music]
already
I am here
[Music]
all right
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sticks are a little too hard to get out
but we can just play online I mean you
get to see all the Ridiculousness of all
the uh all the online Antics for other
people
[Music]
we got balrog up first corex 69.
so have you played much of him so far
um today I have yesterday I was getting
beat up but
I did some of this I did some of his
trials or did all his trials
and they're fun they're really fun it's
just that it's a new balance that people
have to get used to
no more no more uppercutting or no more
head-butting
nice
I I can't talk when I play Street
Fighter I mean it's really difficult to
do that I know
oh you just go straight up
Dad that one punch just takes off like a
two-thirds or a third of the life
you win so we'll get a salty run back
but this corex 69 if he even wants one
you might just be done if you back out
of this you're really salty
I like these points oh yeah fresh clean
on my account too it's like having a
Smurf again round one
fight
sir
so you're teaching him how to block
right here
I love his Target combos are really fun
it was just mashing
oh damn we call that the unblockable
that happens
please
learning a little bit
a little more defensive
let's do it that's what you do online
yeah
see a little bit of lag
do it do it
you know he wants to
oh
nice alrighty
now we can switch this to some uh yeah I
think we should we should see her
because she's she has a whole lot of
stuff going on
you can have actually one of our CNET
engineers in the back here do it while
we commentate yeah yeah
all right let's see uh we think we have
to make a new room
yeah go to that well yeah you have to go
to the main menu
hey don't disappoint tan yeah you gotta
press start
then battle settings
characters
all right yeah there's not enough colors
bro just pick a boogie
did it save
D otherwise you're playing Battle Royale
[Music]
so have you have you had a chance to
play any Ibuki yet Ibuki feels pretty
good also yeah to be honest
ly has a higher learning curve yeah
especially with the like having to
recharge your kunai is like yeah it
makes you it makes it some sparingly
yeah like they're really good
really good for like they made it more
situational yeah yeah uh Target combos
are pretty safe for the most part they
can still be punished but only jab
punish
she's she's gonna have a high learning
curve yeah but I can see I can see her
being used a lot yeah
going to require a lot of training
yes here we go
who are you gonna get it's gonna be a
bronzer I'm going against Alex
[Laughter]
get your predictions in come on come on
come on it's gonna be a Ryu player
he this is his very first time ever
playing the game he's level one he's
from Brazil so the
lag might be it might be a little like
to be honest we should have set
confirmation
run a train on him tan come on
don't disappoint
pressure
Vegas Yes this stage is so nice I know
it looks really good look
oh god
dude the guys you see the characters in
the background just kind of lagging and
like just being sped up
oh you're good
oh yeah
there you go
even the other day even with all that
lag
is everything just jumping around kind
of you just know what he's gonna do all
right it looks a little better
man
yeah you should practice it what's your
crush counter uh standing roundhouse
into something oh the the jumping kit oh
yes
look at that
oh you have to bait out the Tatsu
I think we'll run it back it's Brazilian
see if he doesn't he'll be shamed for
life
Dragon Ball Z time yeah I agree
if we had Xenoverse 2 I would play if we
had they the devs didn't leave it here
fight
oh
that's too bad
Crush counter no
lean heavily on that Roundhouse
there
it's simple
you got your feature Girl by the way I
want to see those bombs
oh
you got another one right
now
you know you can hit the ball yes and
like pop it up yeah you can't control it
like like in Marvel
um like beautiful Joe's bomb or anything
you can't detonate it whenever you want
yeah I I really don't know how the
detonation works
it's just we're still it looks like it's
just on a timer
yeah
but you can combo with it so I'm pretty
sure
there you go
oh yeah
sure just oh yeah we're just gonna let
him have it
oh God
come on come on
don't forget you have super
huh
oh my goodness yeah he just he's just
flipping around the stage right now
whoa
it's still it was still active
you saw that
yeah
like I think when he kicked it it like
extended its time maybe
I'm tempted to play bookie but I can't
deny you a chance of Revenge no
no you don't want to be sent to Losers
no
oh God man killing me
I I know we play local so much I know
don't play someone in South America this
is what happens
[Music]
hurry up
[Laughter]
I had that feeling
throw your head
you can't press anything oh what is he
doing
do you think he even knows how to use
the engine
oh
to be to be fair because of the lag yeah
it's a reaction window is so small
there we go there again every time let
him do it again
slim calm down a little bit
oh yeah there we go what the hell was
that
You're Gonna Lose now
[Laughter]
he's gonna jab you to death
from half life oh God
don't let him do this man
it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen
oh my God
terrible
you
oh wait when are you gonna go back to
balrog I can play with you maybe okay
yeah I have I have their uh they're
alternate costumes yeah
I thought they didn't see it in the uh
um it might not be under colors wait go
back to it
I don't want to mess up it's queue
though hmm it's okay oh that's fine just
let it go we'll get it next time
[Music]
and those those crouching crouching Jabs
man I do want to avoid anyone out of
country from playing that's a good idea
see if you have that yes you can battle
off it sweet
which one's that one
um
no wait is it the dress
I can't remember does she have a ninja
one other than
her Depot one yeah uh I think it might
be her story one I don't I didn't do
that one yet I think story mode is the
sundress oh it's a sundress okay and
then this is the other one
where's everyone is there one off just
playing uh playing story mode right now
no one's online
people working on Friday no
so how long did story mode end up being
it was about Let's see we started at two
I would say close to three hours
yeah let's do it yeah it was close to
three hours
no we're actually hardwired in good good
that's the way you gotta do it
close to how long two hours about three
hours actually yeah
and just it just the store just jumps
from place like Locale Locale then
they're just following everyone and then
getting into misunderstandings and no
one no one ever talks about the problems
they just say
I think there was one point which which
Cami was like oh yeah I like this one
look at those bangs
it doesn't doesn't quite look like her
yeah
so okay wrong not bad
let's hope that connection is perfect
this costume just got stored though at
least round one
fight
you play a little bit Laura right yeah
you know which is capable of
oh no he's set up
oh my God I stuffed it yeah yeah okay
it's pretty solid play yeah looking for
the jump
round two
fights
I gotta find another way in
yeah
they're just always jumping yeah
oh my God he doesn't think so
oh that was it
nice
tan do you want to give it a try I do
yeah there you go we're gonna give back
yourself
he's not he's not fooling around
oh come on
all right round one
fight
yep
oh yeah you can do that reset after that
why is it anti-airing you
there we go that's that's how it's done
Julio
yeah
there we go yeah
oh
[Music]
showed her the knife that's it
foreign
thank you
well now he's fine he's finally noticing
those jumps
oh he got you yeah oh tan you
Mr rug we'll make that our last one I
ideally
end off on a win yeah we always wanted
not to be that cocky you know
if we was again we're just gonna rage
quit right now
switch it up
again no get his other costume this
battle one yeah
his story wasn't the story what's the
other one oh yeah it's a story one
that's the one with the gold gloves oh I
love that one all right we're going with
this
come on someone from the United States
[Music]
assistant
yeah that's that story mode was
something else did you get to play
yurian and jury in that story yeah for
like I think about two two or three two
or three matches so it was like a very
very tiny bit but did they feel like
unrefined or what oh it's hard to say I
didn't actually I I let Scott play
yurien and I play jury jury feels a
little bit different like
um I need to like I had such a limited
amount of time with her I couldn't
figure out how to work her Fireballs
um but apparently like that's that's
changed a little bit and then also her
her pinwheel move is like a sure you can
movement now oh really and so I think
they added like another like kick for
the for I think Corsica Ford
or sorry core Circle back
um it's like some sweeping like lunge
kick like that it looks like an overhead
still have a dive kick I think they got
rid of that actually oh man yeah that's
that's kind of good because I got hit by
five I know I mean that's what most
people would do if they didn't know the
player because you could just do that
into Ultra yeah
all matchmaking
we just won one more
[Music]
how much stuff did you buy did you buy a
package
um like the season pass or anything yes
no because it's just bought them all
individually yeah because the season
pass doesn't come with like some of the
costumes I think yeah it it comes with
like one I think they said One Premium
one for each of the DLC characters but
then remember like was it guile and Alex
were just we're already available for I
think it was until today was the last
time last day they were free yes yeah I
had to buy them earlier actually yeah
even though we've been playing with them
yeah I know like now now we actually
have to own it
and there is nobody playing online
or there's so many people getting
matched up
tan I'm gonna give you another shot
yes I need to step out for a second
there you go
you can play a regular Wiki
and hopefully a match comes soon
[Music]
uh yeah let's let's hop in the train
while we're waiting
oh you can go to the casino
high roller casino
[Music]
I played I only played their trials and
that's like all the knowledge I have
them so far my Kabuki plays like she
still has her Target combos she still
has like a glove the basic moves except
for like the neck breaker
but like it's good I guess for people
who have played her in the past it's
gonna take a long take a little while to
get used to her
her kunai is having to regenerate
like it's a little yeah you just kind of
throw them out
yeah when that bomb explodes you can
pretty much get like a 50 50 almost and
you can't see anything
still waiting on an opponent
no one
no no no no no
I'm really surprised right now there's
no one
let's try that uh that one combo that I
was telling you back again
you picked balrog though right yeah
yeah that's fine
it's gonna be Ken player
you think yes
can
or they're also gonna be playing balance
twice in a row
[Music]
know who everyone's gonna pick just you
just feel it he has a five win streak
does he now
is that your wallet Joey yeah it is it's
a little beat up
I can't wait to see what this can does
to you
oh he just does it
hasn't thrown a single uh sure you can
yet
I'm a little worried
whipped to throw
okay
nice there we go
[Applause]
round two
three
there it is oh
one time you did it do you know his
Crush counter
oh my God
I even throw it out there all the time
better
oh it does can't go through fireballs
oh I love that yeah that's how you come
with the the Stomps
so commanding you win
all right we can we can put we can send
us send everyone home with a win here
no pressure by the way no no pressure
because if I lose too straight I will
rage quit on stream okay
let's take all his points come on
round one
fight
oh really
wow
three
throw a fireball
just wakes up with those Jabs
it works
there we go oh come on
nice oh my God I failed
round two
fight
s
you might have
we just jazzing back and backs off
so frustrating just don't take any of
the bait
I want to see some v-trigger if you want
to get to that point
[Music]
you're gonna you're gonna be
disappointed with that
so disappointing oh man that win
that about wraps it up you guys have
been playing for hours yeah we've been
here a while we've gone through the
entire story mode and I think we're uh I
think we're good to just to finish ready
to wrap it up yeah yeah
um we're probably gonna go to the
cabinet and play some more
so you know we'll there'll be more
Street Fighter after this but um yeah
thanks for all the people out there
still watching managed to stick around
for the whole the entire story mode and
also for you know a couple matches of
balrogen to bookie thanks you know if
you're watching this on YouTube
subscribe twitch
gamespot.com wherever you are you know
be sure to follow us for more live
streams and hopefully more Street
Fighter in the coming months when they
release more updates to that as well
um so yeah thanks everyone we'll see you
so much we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
okay